think I'm a master of [music] parking. I
feel like I have a little bit of a sense of space.
No, it's
Jisoon. The
name is just a bit
unusual. Since it's
called Jisoo, I think there are a lot of nicknames that make the pronunciation of the name a little
cute.
What is
style?  I
wear it very comfortably when I get off,
but now when I'm meeting with friends or
spending some personal time alone, I
think I wear it a little more
femininely.  I think I wear it a lot in style
Today, I
feel like I'm
dressed up a little bit
What are the fance card Link
I
sing the most.  Among
Black Pink's songs, I
really like love to hame. It's fun to
sing and I
don't know anything when I listen to it.
These days, I was really scared again. I
laughed at the scissors and the ghosts. Can Ji-
soo is
perfect. Can-G Speak
Japanese.  It's
easy, but then it
becomes
very difficult after some difficulties such as grammar.
Feeling Also, if I
learn another language, English
I think I want to learn English the most. English
can be used in many places, so it is still
possible to understand it to some extent, but I think it
would be nice if I could do it more comfortably.
I think I
have a Kenji Drive driver's license now.
Driving I think I'm a very
good driver. I've
never had a hard time parking. I
think I'm a master of parking.
I
was very excited because I was filming a vintage car. They
asked if I could drive a
vintage
car,
but it was
so vintage that I could
n't drive it.  Even
though I was learning that short thing, my
hands were all torn and it was so painful and
hard. So
those who can do this black thing perfectly are really
people with great persistence and perseverance.  If it
was the gayageum, he would have made it a little
more comfortable.
So
next time, if I learn it, I
would like to learn the
gayageum.
I don't like food very much and I
like to clean it up. I
rather like to clean up what I cooked. I'm
really scared of knives, so the
first dish I learned was
fried eggs. Mom or dad.
I don't have one, I just
cook and eat what my mom taught me, or the
dishes I'm most confident in are
able to cook basic dishes like egg soy sauce rice and kimchi fried rice.  It's a
style that takes a long time to get closer and talk just
enough to ease the awkwardness.  I
think there's something I can't deny the most. When I saw just one letter at a time, I think
Ai was right, End was right,
Tea
was right, and Blood was right.  That's
why I
like being alone the most, and I
don't make appointments as much as possible, and when I finish work, I
feel like I'm going home right away and I'm alone.  Since there are
a lot of times when I'm in a seat,
I'm not
going to listen
to people who are meticulously catching up or directing me.  I
think that this song brought out the charm of my husky voice more, so I
hope you listen to it and like it a lot. I was always happy because I was the youngest. Being the youngest was
the best. Being the
youngest
was forgiven and there was
nothing lacking.  I never
thought of having a younger sister. That's
why I was
shocked by Stick becoming the eldest sister in Blackpink.
I
grew up as the youngest, so I
became the eldest sister.  I have
so many friends from abroad and
I treat them comfortably, so I don't feel like an older sister that much. Because of that,
sometimes I
feel like the maknae, and now I really
like it.  This
is an album that I put a lot of effort into to include my own colorful image that I found after much thought. It's an
album that I poured a lot of sincerity and affection into, so
I hope Blink will love it as much.
y is Jisoo
Cult Tattle Lab It Kim  After
all the greetings were filmed, we
had a vacation in Hwahwa for a few days by ourselves. The four of us were
going to Turtle Bay together, and while talking with Jennie
in the car, that kind of talk
came up.
Uh,
butwhy do you
have a name for wheat? When I
asked who decides these things, he said he decides
so what? Then
I can make it, so
can my sister.  Uh, then, since I’m
going to Turtle Be right now, then
I want to be G-Stutle Laby Kim. That’s why Sea Star Trap became Kim.
I think I cried on ,
so there's no reason like this.
When I come alone, the reason is
more than something. It's just a bit
sad.  I
think people are a bit curious because I don't come so much.
Jisoo Camilla Cabello Camila Cabello's
Liar was
covered at our concert before the solo song came out.  I was
thinking a lot,
so I was going to a song, but
rather than listening to a certain song like this, like a shuffle, the
song came out more randomly, and then
the song came out, but
somehow I thought I could do it on stage in a certain way.  It
felt like I was drawing a lot, so I
thought I should do this song, so I made it go right away. It was
an honor. I got a
call from the LA concert, so
I was so happy that you talked to me like this, how about we
decorate the stage together?  Passionately,
let's
do something like this together here. Let's do something like this.